the VMAs feature Trump bashing students
at the University of North Carolina tear
down a statue and I have the two
stupidest stories you have ever heard
back to bak back they are incredible I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
these stories are so good that I can't
even get through the opener that's how
amazing these stories are we'll get to
all of the latest news but first let's
talk about the fact that you brush your
teeth wrong okay we know you do you go
to the dentist and then they ask you how
often you brush your teeth and how long
are you brushing your teeth and then you
lie to your dentist and then you go home
you feel good about yourself but you're
a liar the reality is that you need
equip you need quip electric toothbrush
it's the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amounts of
vibration into a slimmer design at a
fraction of the cost of bulkier
traditional electric brushes that gives
you guiding pulses that alert you when
to switch sides making brushing the
right amount of effortless and quip also
comes the mount that suctions right to
your mirror and unsticks use as a cover
for hygienic travel anywhere whether
it's going in your gym bag or carry-on
and because the thing that cleans your
mouth should also be clean quip
subscription plan refreshes your brush
on a dentist recommended schedule
delivering new brush heads every three
months for just five bucks as soon as
you sign up you never have to worry
about it again quip is backed by a
network of over 10,000 dental
professionals it really is fantastic it
travels really easily when you replace
the battery it takes about five seconds
it's really simple you don't have to
have that giant charging station they
hook up next to your mirror and takes up
ugly mirror space go check it out right
now quip starts at just 25 bucks if you
go to get quip comm slash Shapiro right
now you'll get your first refill pack
free with a quip electric toothbrush
that is your first refill pack free at
get quip comm slash Shapiro again GE tqu
IP comm slash up here oh I love my quip
electric toothbrush and you will to get
clipped comm slash Shapiro so last night
was the Video Music Awards the most
important of all award ceremonies
because it is deeply important that we
have award ceremonies that give awards
to people who earn millions and millions
of dollars for making crappy music that
is popular and I know I know you're
gonna tell me that I'm an elitist in my
tastes right because I like good things
and just because things are popular
doesn't make them good see the movie
Titanic for an example but if avatar is
an even better example what is more
telling about the VMAs than anything
else is the amount of political
posturing that happens at the VMAs the
reason that Democrats are having trouble
in the middle of the country is because
there's an elitist feel to the Democrats
the reason Donald Trump won is not
because there are all these dispossessed
people in the center of the country who
felt economically left behind the reason
that Trump won is because Trump was a
giant middle finger to a bunch of people
in Hollywood in New York that's really
what Trump was what Trump was was people
getting sick of being told that they
were racist sexist bigoted homophobes
and Trump responding by basically
flipping everyone
and the Republican base cheering yeah
because we were so sick of hearing over
and over and over that we are terrible
people and that was reinforced all
throughout the 2016 campaign for example
Hillary Clinton bringing out ads with
Lena Dunham who may have molested her
sister but she was supposed to be this
great Hollywood moral icon who is going
to tell us all about how we ought to
think about issues like abortion and the
DNC replete with all sorts of stars and
and people cutting versions of fight
song with Elizabeth Banks and and the
stars of the pitch perfect movies and
everybody in the middle confirm it
really that's your pitch to me in Ohio
is Lady gaga that's your big pitch
thanks for that the VMAs are another way
for the Democratic Left to reinforce
just how out of touch they are and
what's funny is that the people who are
actually in the business of politics
know this so sherrod Brown is a senator
from Ohio he's a little bit more
moderate than the typical Democrat not
much he's got that wild hair over there
but he's the guy who's in touch with
that blue-collar base in Ohio right he
has to be elected in the same state that
Trump won by something like eight points
well sure Brown was on TV yesterday on
the MSNBC's and he said the Democrats
aren't really showing that they're
fighting for the little guy
well I think Democrats have not talked
enough about fighting for the little guy
meaning it really our party to into life
so to free-trade you're not there to go
there to the party has been to free
trade but the Republicans have been more
free trade but that's our problem to
show where we are and fight for workers
but I don't think the voters necessarily
think what we should be thinking and
that as you fight for the little guy
whether she punches a clock whether he
works in a diner whether she works
construction whether it works in
manufacturing so let's ask a question
those people who are punching a clock
working in a diner working in
manufacturing and people who are working
on assembly lines or who are going to a
factory in the evenings do they really
want to hear from a bunch of pampered
celebrities who are millions of dollars
to read lines written by others or sing
songs written by others or warble
off-key songs that are then later
auto-tuned for millions of dollars so
they want to hear from those people
about what America really constitutes is
that really what's their cup of tea the
answer of course is no and yet that's
what Democrats continue to to resonate
to the the Democratic elite are wildly
out of touch with all the people who are
in the middle of the country which is
why they continue to cater the folks
over at the VMAs so the VMAs Video Music
Awards it used to
actually celebrate music of a sort now
it's basically just a place for
political posturing Kevin Hart was
hosting this thing with a Tiffany
Haddish is that how it's pronounced and
and Kevin Hart he he started off by
joking about President Trump a lot which
is a brave thing what my favorite part
of this is that when Kevin Hart jokes
about all this what you'll hear is a
triumphalism in his voice look at how
brave I am it's very reminiscent of
Robert DeNiro at the Emmy Awards where
he started shouting fu Trump and then
raising his arms raising his fists
because he had single-handedly deposed
the President of the United States under
Article 32 of the Constitution of the
United States if an actor who once
played a boxer shouts fu Trump at the
president he's no longer the president
so naturally Robert De Niro is very
enthusiastic about this he got a
standing ovation for shouting fu Trump
so going to virtue signal in front of a
bunch of people who totally agree with
you at Rockefeller Center in the middle
of New York City or in Los Angeles this
is the height of courage in the in the
entertainment sphere it's just like
Normandy it's like the guys who are
coming off the boats and fighting the
Nazis
that's Kevin Hart and Tiffani hottish
saying after you Trump this makes them
feel good inside it makes them feel like
they've done something a virtuous and
strong in a room full of people who
agree with them and think that virtue
and strength come from shouting at the
President of the United States here's
Kevin Hart joking about about Trump
again if you if you don't think this is
off-putting then you're really not
following how America works these days
I'm looking at this like it's game day
people but do not worry because at this
game you guys are allowed to kneel you
can do whatever the hell you want
there's no old white man that can stop
you do it I mean beats pop off bad
language people went to the bathroom to
send out crazy tweets it's basically
like the typical day at the White House
and your face struck suck it in your
face Trump suck it well first of all
funny would be good hey Kevin Hart used
to be a comedian now he's just a short
guy who yells at the president and he's
one of the few people in America that
I'm allowed to call short because it's
actually shorter than I am but in any
case I'm gonna least take a moment to
enjoy that but Kevin Hart yeah doing
this routine at the Video Music Awards
broadcast across the nation watched by
seven people but treasured by the
celebrity culture in the Democratic
Party is that sort of thing going to
hurt Trump or is it going to help Trump
the answer of course is it's radically
going to help from every time people in
the culture decide to insert themselves
into politics everyone else gets
really really annoyed but it wasn't just
that and there was somebody named logic
I assume that was his given name I said
he came out of his mother and his mother
said I shall call you logic but
apparently he's some sort of rapper
don't know don't really care and he did
some song called one day he ran out
while doing this song wearing a shirt
that said F the wall and then he brought
out a bunch of kids who are either
illegal immigrants or children of
activists and they're all wearing shirts
that say we are all human beings right
ok but some of you are here illegally
like there are lots of different types
of human beings all over planet Earth
and in the United States as well that
does not answer the question I mean you
could go to prison and say and have
everybody wear shirts saying we are all
human beings like there are lots of
types of human beings that's I'm going
to say these kids are bad but again the
virtue signaling in the room is really
strong also if the wall I just wonder
whether mr. logic actually has a wall
around his house I assume he lives in
some sort of gated community he has
security it's very easy to pick on
celebrities this way because they live
in a world that they don't actually
inhabit there's a great book by charles
murray called coming apart and what the
book is really about is all of these
people who's kind of white upper crust
elites who live on the coasts and they
push a message of social liberalism they
push that single motherhood is totally
wonderful then they push that abortion
is totally cool and they push that not
saving your money is fine they push all
of these socially liberal messages about
big government and high taxes and then
they take all their money and they store
it in offshore bank accounts and they
get married and they have kids just like
a normal family in 1955 but everybody in
the middle of the country who listens to
them follows this advice and then they
live crappy lives well that's exactly
what happens when you see these
celebrities talking about after the wall
you think these people are going to be
affected by the lack of a wall on the
southern border they're not ranchers in
Arizona
okay these folks are not going to be
affected by this all that a lack of a
wall means to these folks is that they
have cheaper illegal immigrant labor to
do their lawns legitimately that's what
celebrities and all I do most of the
time celebrities who are interacting
with illegal immigrants are doing so in
terms of household service seriously I
live in LA I promise you I know a lot of
these celebrities and most of them when
they talk about illegal immigrants
they're talking about that they want a
cheap housekeeper or a cheap nanny now
listen I don't blame any of the people
who are coming across the border to live
a better life in the United States I do
blame a system that allows people to
cross the border illegally without
it seems to me that the least a country
can do is check the folks coming across
the border to make sure that number one
they are safe number two they are
educated and number three they're going
to contribute to society and not mooch
off of society but these folks it
doesn't affect them it doesn't matter to
them they don't live in poorer
neighborhoods where culture changes when
thousands of people come across the
border and they don't speak the native
tongue and they bring customs from home
right that that doesn't actually make
any difference to people who are living
in gated communities and gated
establishments doesn't make any
difference to them because they are
gated off from everyone else and the
only actual contact they have with the
illegal immigration doesn't involve any
additional crime it doesn't involve any
sort of additional poverty that exists
in certain communities in the United
States thanks to illegal immigration it
doesn't actually change any of that for
them so it's easy for them to go up
there and virtue signal in front of all
of their rich friends
here was the aforementioned logic again
I'm so confused by rapper names I can't
even express it but here here is logic
performing one day in a wall that reads
F the way in a shirt that reads F the
wall
[Applause]
I really have to admit it's almost
impossible not to watch this particular
number and just get flashes to pop star
with Andy Samberg because he is one guy
singing like wait who is it George
Michael in it with George Michael
singing and then some guy rapping about
social justice in the background it's
really it's really incredible so if you
haven't seen that movie you should go
check it out it's very obscene but it's
really really funny but that's what all
of this stuff is and it is inherently
absurd it's inherently absurd they
didn't just do that they also cut a TV
promo to get out the vote which is
really exciting they had all of these
celebrities who cut a TV promo trying to
tell everybody it's important to Rock
the Vote because this is what we need is
celebrities telling people to vote
I would prefer frankly that fewer
uninformed people vote rather than
everybody who watches the VMAs voting
also if people are voting because the
celebrity told you to then you probably
shouldn't be voting in the first place
the final word on this comes courtesy of
Michael avenatti who legitimately showed
up at the VMAs I will explain in just
one second but first let's talk about
something deeply exciting your air
filters oh yes I know you're living in
your home right now you're thinking I
don't need an air filter yeah go open up
that vent I promise you when you open it
up what it's gonna be
is a bunch of gunk in your air filter
and you've been breathing that in for
months because you didn't care enough to
think about the exciting topic of your
air filters well this is why you need
filter by it's America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses with over 600 sizes
that ship for free within 24 hours plus
they're manufactured right here in the
United States I recommend that you
subscribe so you don't forget to
regularly replace those filters like I
do plus they knock five percent off the
order when you do subscribe you know
there there's a lot of smoke and dust in
the air particularly in places like
California right now you're gonna want
to go out and make sure that your air
quality is the best it can be
save time save money breathe better with
filter by comm again that's filter B Y
comm filter by accom and again subscribe
so that they will automatically send you
the filters that you need on a regular
schedule and they knock five percent off
the order we use it here at the daily
wire offices I use filter by at home and
they have customizable sizes as well if
that's something you need filter by calm
again filter BY calm and tell them that
I sent you by telling them that you
listened to ben shapiro show okay so the
best part of this and what when I say
that the Democrats and the VMAs are
basically one thing that the celebrity
culture of the Democratic Party has
basically eaten the Democratic Party I
mean that apocryphally I don't mean that
in any sort of vague sense Barack Obama
is sort of the celebrity to the
celebrity culture and the the mutual
back scratching of celebrity that went
on during the Obama administration was
pretty incredible everybody in Hollywood
thought Barack Obama was a celebrity and
Barack Obama wanted to hang out with the
celebrities who thought that he was a
celebrity so the merger of celebrity and
politics was already in place long
before we elected a reality television
star to the presidency of the United
States Barack Obama was actually the
first reality TV star to be president of
the United States he had no real
political experience he came out of
nowhere TV glorified him and he was
considered a celebrity more than he was
a politician even before he was elected
president of the United States in any
case what this leads to is the actual
merger of reality TV in politics which
is I have to admit deeply entertaining
so Michael avenatti you'll remember is
the lawyer for stormy Daniels he became
famous literally by representing a porn
star who once took the president
this is his legitimate claim to fame the
only reason he is famous is because
stormy the annuals during Shark Week
nailed the president and then went away
for many years because the president
paid her lots of money to go away and
then in an act of brazen bravery decided
to come out and tell her important story
she doesn't allege the president
actually abused her in any way she just
wanted to come out makes money off of
this thing so she could strip for higher
rates but Michael avenatti is her lawyer
and he's been out there saying that he
is going to tear down the president he's
the lawyer who's finally going to bring
down the President of the United States
and he shows up at the VMAs now
everybody's sort of laughing at this I
think Michael a Vinod he has a shot at
the 2020 nomination I do I'll explain
why after you watch Michael avenatti
talk about why he's the Video Music
Awards are you doing here well you know
I was invited to this great event it's a
pretty cool event and I thought I'd show
up you surprised to be invited a little
bit a little bit but you know hopefully
it won't be the first time well it is
the first time hopefully it won't be the
last time so are you really considering
a run for president I am I'm serious
about it I'm seriously looking at it I'm
traveling around talking to people in
the country and you know I've been
really surprised at how much enthusiasm
there is out there for the potential so
I'm gonna make a decision I want to be
smart about it deliberately you know why
because the VMAs is a is a signifier of
democratic in if you want to know what
time
let's feel all you have to do is really
watch the VMAs you'll know Democrats
think you have to look at their various
policy proposals and you have to talk to
the Democrat socialist of America and
all the rest if you don't know what they
feel watch the VMAs and that is a
visceral hatred for the President of the
United States and Michael heaven Adi
represents that in a pretty solid way
his entire claim to fame is yelling at
Trump and so now he's at the VMAs
yelling at Trump and people look at him
they go I like that guy you know why cuz
he yells at Trump that's awesome
if the Democrats disappoint in 2018 if
they don't take back Congress in 2018
for example you could see such a strong
backlash so much anger that somebody
like a Vinod he could actually win some
primaries they so Leon I'm the only guy
in this room who's actually sued the
President of the United States I'm the
only guy in this room who's willing to
say basta I'm the only one in this room
who's aggressive enough to take on the
president that has some appeal to
Democrats because the VMAs represent the
it'd Michael avenatti is the it and the
Democrats have basically decided to cave
to their it'd as opposed to following
the sort of blue-collar tactics that the
chaired Brown would prefer okay
meanwhile as I say you know the
President of the United States Trump was
elected because of cultural issues so
here are a couple of cultural issues
there there are a lot of stories that we
we use in radio and podcasting on
Twitter that signify this is why Trump
won you get that a lot this is why Trump
won something dumb happens and people
tweet out this is why Trump won but
these dumb stories actually are sort of
why Trump won so here is one of those
examples today this is such a great
story this is courtesy of The Associated
Press already Mandalay International the
parent company of Nabisco has redesigned
the packaging of its Barnum's animals
crackers after a lending to pressure
from people for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals PETA which has been protesting
the use of the animals in circuses for
more than 30 years wrote a letter to
Mandalay in the spring of 2016 calling
for a redesign given the egregious
cruelty inherent in circuses that use
animals and the public swelling
opposition to the exploitation of
animals used for entertainment we urged
Nabisco to update its packaging in order
to show animals who are free to roam in
their natural habitats PETA said in its
letter
monsley agreed and started working on a
redesign in the meantime the crackers
namesake circus Ringling Brothers and
Barnum & Bailey folded for good
146 year-old circus had removed two
elephants from its shows in 2016 because
of pressure from PETA it closed down in
May 2017 do to slow ticket sales the
redesign retains all
the coloring but instead of showing the
animals and cages implying they're
traveling in boxcars for the circus the
new boxes feature a zebra elephant lion
giraffe and gorilla wandering side by
side in a grassland the outline of
acacia trees can be seen in the distance
so this was deeply important People for
the Ethical Treatment of Animals has now
has now released the fake cookie animals
well you know it's no longer enough to
have free-range chickens we'd have to
have free-range cookie chickens very
very important but let's let's be real
about this all of this is fun and games
until the cookie lion and the and the
cookie tiger decide to eat the
gingerbread man at that point it really
gets seriously ugly the muffin man takes
it right in the neck from the the line
that has now been released from his cage
on the Barnum's animals
crackers really doing important things
here in the United States and this is
why people like Oh screw political
correctness screw this this is just
ridiculous
that is not even the most politically
correct story of the day this one is
spectacular okay so this is from health
line health line is a publication I
believe they are connected with men's
health in some way and they have
something reviewed by Janet Brito PhD
it's called the LGBTQIA z b yl safe sex
guide it's good times and here is it's
so good it's so good so they have
decided that they are going to rename
genitalia rename them to be more
sensitive to transgender folks you ready
for this it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable
for birthing 1,000 time my wife happens
to be a doctor which means fuses medical
terminology even when I teach my
children what genitalia are my
daughter's four and a half years old and
knows the name of genitalia and then she
calls it her privates own shoes
euphemism just like most parents I don't
want my kids running around in stores
screaming penis or vagina right that's
just what we do but that's because my
children are children and when we
actually discuss actual biology it's
good to know the terminology and not to
say pee pee right it's good to know the
actual terminology however it's
apparently very very bad very bad
because here's what Health Line says
these guides to many guides with regard
to LGBTQ issues often unnecessarily
gender body parts as being male parts
and female parts so it yes
correct you know like in every sexually
dimorphic species which is to say every
animal species on planet Earth
the penis is a male part and the vagina
is a female part because these still
have biological meanings because we're
not idiots but apparently we are idiots
I've assumed too much okay these guys
often unnecessarily gender body parts as
being male parts and female parts and
refer to sex with women or sex with men
excluding those who identify as
non-binary okay you can't have sex with
a non-binary body part it doesn't exist
that's not a thing unless you are
screwing a tree that's not a thing and
many individuals don't see body parts as
having a gender people have a gender but
body parts have a sex what in the world
are you talking about are you saying
that it's just some sort of social
construct that the presence of a penis
seems to be connected with male genetics
that's a social construct okay I can't
wait to give you the punchline of this
cuz the punchline of this is so
unbelievably good okay the punchline is
just it's astonishingly good but first
we need to talk about your nutritional
habits everything that we've been taught
about weight loss is making us unhealthy
the supplements we've been accustomed to
are loaded with sugar and artificial
ingredients and processed foods if
you're on the hunt for healthy
supplements that are packed with
nutrients that actually promote weight
loss then you should take a look at 3:10
nutrition 310 nutrition is a brand you
can trust to help you lose weight and
live out a healthy lifestyle with the
help of a variety of awesome products
folks at the office are using 3:10
nutrition they make 310 meal replacement
shakes which are packed with top-quality
plant-based proteins vitamins minerals
superfoods probiotics 310 lemonade water
enhancer for folks who don't like the
taste of water instead you can get 310
lemonade which helps you stay hydrated
and they have an online community as
well you can join the 310 community on
Facebook and Twitter it's a great way to
engage with hundreds of thousands of
people for support and helpful tips on
eating healthy and nutrition join the
310 nutrition community for free go to
310 family com in addition so that great
community 310 nutrition is offering my
listeners there 310 starter nutrition
kit same give it a try for just 14 bucks
you'll receive an assortment of 310 meal
replacement shakes a meal plan ebook a
gift card many other products don't miss
out on this great offer and the free
community joining 310 nutrition is a
great way to engage with thousands of
like-minded individuals also looking to
live a healthy lifestyle go to 310
family com that's three one zero family
com 310 family calm and go check it out
right now
at 3:10 started in tuition kit for just
14 bucks okay so here's the punch line
to this LGBTQIA Z a Y guide okay here's
the punch line so they've already said
these guys unnecessarily gender body
parts as being male parts in female
parts so here is their solution here's
their solution the notion that a penis
is exclusively a male body part and a
vulva is exclusively a female body part
is inaccurate no it's not by using the
word parts to talk about genitals and
using medical terms for anatomy without
attaching a gender to it we become much
more able to effectively discuss safe
sex in a way that's clear and inclusive
for the purpose here it is it's it's so
good it's so good okay there's no way to
pitch how good this is for the purposes
of this guide we will refer to the
vagina as the front hole instead of
solely using the medical term vagina
this is gender inclusive language that's
considerate of the fact that some trans
people don't identify with the labels
the medical community attaches to their
genitals the front hole okay so again my
wife's a doctor if she is doing a
gynecological exam she is not going to
ask a biological woman if she can see
her front hole because that's absurd
that is ridiculous and I'm afraid that
these folks are mixing up their face
hole with their rear hole because
basically their head is up their ass
that's what I'm trying to tell you here
that is so ridiculous but this is how
far we've come you want to know why you
got Trump this is why you got Trump I
know everybody's like what does this
have to do with Trump it has to do with
everybody looks at these stories and we
go that guy okay fine whatever you're
gonna do this fine that that ridiculous
human being let's just make him
president I don't even give a crap
anymore at least he's not doing front
hole at least we're not gonna have a
democratic debate when you're known as
you're a Republican debate or they argue
over the proper terminology for terms
that have been settled by science for
all of history okay so we're not gonna
do this we're not gonna do this
honest-to-god front hall oh yeah
Democrats let's keep going down let's
explore these paths yes yes just great
meanwhile in other ridiculous stories
today this is an amazing story so we
talked yesterday about Asia Argento
Asia Argento is one of the me2 leaders
and she has said that we should believe
all women we should believe all victims
except for that seventeen year old boy
that she apparently molested right who
apparently she paid three hundred eighty
thousand dollars to silence he was a
child actor when she was 37 and he was
17 he invited him to a hotel room where
she apparently essentially had sex with
him
well she said Tuesday and she never had
any sexual relationship with a man who's
accused her of molesting him which is
weird since he actually forwarded a
picture of her in bed with him at a
hotel to the New York Times but here's
what she says she said Tuesday she'd
never had any sexual relationship with a
man who's accused her of molesting him
when he was a minor and that her former
boyfriend the late Anthony Bourdain
urged her to agree to a financial
settlement to end the man's
long-standing persecution of her so
that's a strong tactic blame the dude
who just hung himself that's it that
seems like that's a very strong move by
Asia Argento if that's not true then she
is not only a terrible person she is the
terrible person that is about as
terrible as it gets again what's amazing
about this whole phenomenon with age
Argento is to watch people give her the
benefit of the doubt and read in an area
they would not give anybody else the
benefit of the doubt
you know the Bible is very clear about
judging and what the Bible says it's
very interesting verse the Bible says I
read early quote the Bible but this is
an actual moral rule and the moral rule
is when you judge you are not supposed
to judge in benefit of the rich or in
benefit of the poor why would the Bible
specify you're not supposed to judge and
benefit of the poor we all understand
you don't it would have to specify don't
judge in favor of the rich because
corruption tends to come from rich
people who can pay off judges but the
notion of sympathy for particular
victims allows people to make unjust
decisions okay that is what is happening
here there are a lot of folks on the
Left who are rushing to Asia Argento s
defense and providing her with all sorts
of credibility because they like Asia
Argento we see this on all sides when
president Trump is accused of sexual
abuse people who like Trump like God
none of that's true
and then when keith ellison is abused
accused of sexual abuse people on the
right like yeah that's totally true
and exactly the reverse for democrats
you got to have one standard of guilt or
innocence and you have to have one
standard for the level of evidence
necessary in order for us to determine
whether somebody is actually responsible
for behavior or not the double standard
is pretty telling and that's a pretty
shocking move by Asia Argento right
there if that's not true she's got a
real problem okay meanwhile a big story
that broke last night is that over at
the U
city of North Carolina protestors
knocked over a pro-confederate statue
from 1913 I here are some video is what
it sounded like when a bunch of students
decided to topple silence and which is a
19-13 statue placed on campus in
memoriam of the 300 alumni who served in
the Confederate Army
here is what it sounded like
[Applause]
so pulling down the statue and people
are celebrating and cheering and picking
the statue and stomping on the statue as
though they've just pulled down a statue
of Stalin or a statue of Saddam Hussein
in the aftermath of Nepal of the Soviet
Union or the destruction of the Hussein
regime I think that there is a solid
case that silence ham should not be on
public property I'm not a big fan of
removing monuments I tend to agree with
Condoleezza Rice who I think made this
case very well she says I am a firm
believer and keep your history before
you and so I don't actually want to
rename things that were named for slave
owners I want us to have to look at
those names and recognize what they did
and to be able to tell our kids what
they did and for them to have a sense of
their own history when you start wiping
out your history sanitizing your history
to make you feel better it's a bad thing
I agree with Condoleezza Rice I think
that people should be forced to look at
that statue and then cope with the
legacy of slavery in the United States
and the legacy of the Confederacy it is
not fair to say that this statue was
merely a sort of anodyne tribute to
people who died in a war because when it
was actually dedicated in 1913 it was
pretty obviously a symbol of anti-black
hatred at the time Julian Carr who's a
local KKK member who helped dedicate the
statue said this at the actual
dedication ceremony said there are no
words that I have been able to find in
the vocabulary of the English language
that adequately expressed my feelings in
the presence of this occasion and then
he gets to the the truly horrible part
100 yards from where we stand
what's the 90 days perhaps after my
return from Appomattox I horsewhipped a
Negro wench under her until her skirts
hung in shreds because upon the streets
of this quiet village she had publicly
insulted in the line to Southern lady
and then rushed for protection to these
university buildings where was stationed
a garrison of 100 federal soldiers I
performed the pleasing duty in the
immediate presence of the entire
garrison and for 30 nights afterwards
slept with a double-barrel shotgun under
my head so yeah the statute was pretty
well connected with some awful egregious
evil behavior no question but does that
mean that we should start tearing down
statues I don't think number one we
should turn around statues and number
two I don't think that meaning I don't
think statue should be removed number
one number two I think that we are
setting a really bad precedent when we
are actually having mobs of people tear
down statues for for a couple of reasons
the main reason why it's really bad when
people tear down statues when mobs tear
down statues is that you understand why
people did it in the former Soviet Union
or wipe
in the hussein regime because
legitimately a regime that was
repressive had fallen there was no
government that had now taken the now
taken sort of control to get rid of the
old vestiges and so the people in a fit
of wild enthusiasm tore down these old
symbols of tyranny but we have a
democratic government the united states
we have a democratic republic in the
united states the governor of north
carolina is a democrat who doesn't
actually like this monument if you're
telling me that the people who run the
university of north carolina are people
who are emissaries of white supremacy
you're out of your mind
i mean the people who run that
university are very much on the left
these are people who really oppose I'm
sure opposed that statue the point is
that in the United States where you
actually have a redress of grievances
available through the democratic process
to use mob rule as an excuse to do this
he's really bad and it actually leads to
some even worse stuff so I got a letter
from a student at UNC last night to tell
me about this stuff and here's what the
student wrote quote I am a freshman at
the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill tonight students tore down a
Confederate statue on campus that is
known as silence am peaceful protesters
acted just like their name suggests and
destroyed this piece of history chanting
black power and go away cops when police
arrived on the scene by the way it's
worth noting that if you think that the
system of white supremacy is still in
the offing in the United States in 1913
when an evil KKK member horse whipped a
black woman for no apparent reason in
front of a garrison of a hundred federal
officers who did nothing
hey the reverse happened last night a
bunch of police officers stood around
while a bunch of students tore down a
statue in honor of the Confederacy and
they stood around only one person was
arrested and they were there standing
that because he was destroying public
property didn't do anything about it
because they decided that it was
worthwhile to tear it down now I don't
think the cops should have stood around
for that I think the law should be
enforced whatever the law is in a
democratic republic but let's also note
that those same police officers are not
exactly standing up for white supremacy
when they stand around allowing people
to tear a day on a confederate statute
that's just silly hey here's what the
student continued to say here's where it
gets ugly says I walked by to see what I
figured was going to be national news
and that was probably not the smartest
thing for me to do almost immediately
some of these protesters started coming
at me yelling get out of here whitey
which I found ironic cuz they were
holding a sign that said from Durham to
Charlottesville to the White House tear
down racism needless to say I ran back
to my dorm pretty
fast I was hearing from several students
who had similar experiences at UNC so it
turns out that anti-racism only extends
as far as battling the quote unquote
superstructure of white supremacy it
doesn't actually extend to not yelling
at people who happen to be white walking
by this rally as it's happening okay in
just a second I want to talk a little
bit more about kind of student
revolutions and the the youth that are
supposed to save us but first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire
before we get over to that sorry
well before we get over to that we have
a new a new sponsor and the sponsor is
supremely awesome so I've talked about
the Second Amendment a lot on this show
one of the things I've said about the
Second Amendment is the purpose of the
Second Amendment is not hunting the
purpose of the Second Amendment
self-defense and protection against
tyranny you know who agrees with me the
Bravo manufacturing company it was
started in a garage by a marine vet more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that actually
meets combat standards BCM believes the
same level of protection should be
provided to every American whether they
are a private citizen or a professional
BCM is not a sporting arms company the
design engineer and manufacture
life-saving equipment they assume that
each rifle leaving their shop will be
used in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible law-abiding citizen law
enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas each component of a BCM rifle
is hand assemble tested by Americans to
a life-saving standard obviously they
buy by all federal and state law BCM
feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that are not
going to fail the user when they're not
just looking at a paper target when god
forbid somebody is in your home with the
various intent BCM works with leading
instructors of marksmanship sfrom top
levels of America's Special Ops forces
for Marine Corps Force reconnaissance to
US Special Ops forces who can teach the
skills necessary to defend yourself your
family or others to learn more about
Bravo Company manufacturing go to Bravo
Company MFG comm you can check out their
product special offers offers and
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm and go check it out right now
if you want see their videos and learn
more about them youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA you can learn about the
awesome people who make up the company
they're really great folks I've talked
to them Bravo Company MFG comm go check
them out again these weapons were made
for your protection Bravo Company MFG
comm ok so if you want to hear about the
latest in Trump 'ln and and all the rest
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire comm $9.99 a month gets you the
rest of our show live get to the rest of
Michael Moses show live the rest of
Andrew clavin's show live it all
so gets you access to our mailbag which
will be doing on Friday have all of your
most deep deeply held profound questions
answered in real time when you become
part of the mailbag when you get the
annual subscription for $99 here you get
this the greatest in all beverage
vessels behold it feast your eyes upon
this and then if you so choose choose
this and if there's a reason that
Indiana Jones chose this particular
vessel and he survived the bout with the
Holy Grail this may in fact have been
the Holy Grail I can't not my religion I
really don't know but you'll have to
check that out $99 a year and you get
that the the best beverage vessel of all
time also go check us out at YouTube go
over it iTunes we have an Sunday special
coming up this week that's gonna be
awesome
hit the little bell when you subscribe
at YouTube it allows you to to be
updated every time we have a new piece
of content we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so the media are celebrating the fall of
silence Sam again I think there's an
argument to be made whether that statue
ought to be removed from public property
or not I don't think it's a particularly
compelling argument but at least that's
an argument there is no argument that I
can see that a mob should be able to
tear this statue down I don't think mobs
tearing things down is actually a good
thing in the United States mob rule is
generally not something I'm in favor of
but again it's this let it's this
feeling that has now been pushed across
the United States it's this wave of
feeling that the angry you you are in
politics the more justified you are and
that means the youth shall lead us
because the youth are the angriest and
one of the angriest people in the United
States is obviously David hog now David
hog you'll remember from months ago he's
now more obscure he was one of the
parkland survivors he's been on the
cover of magazines he's on the cover of
New York magazine the cover of New York
magazine which is pretty incredible for
a kid who's I guess he's 18 now is 18 he
just is about to graduate high school or
he just graduated high school and he's
extraordinarily politically active which
is fine and he says he wants to run for
Congress and also he curses about Nancy
Pelosi we know that he's authentic
because he says the f-word a lot he says
the reason Republicans are successful
right now is because they're empowering
young people pointing out the Paul Ryan
was 45 when he became Speaker of the
House ignoring the fact the President of
the United States is one thousand two
hundred and seventy two years old his
older Democrats just won't move the F
off the plate and let us take control
Nancy Pelosi is old and then he says he
wants to join Congress and he says a lot
of sloganeering
that doesn't actually have any real
basis in in fact and he's champion as
the face of the new movement on the
cover of New York magazine it's actually
a really weird article because it talks
about him refusing to move his hometown
without his parents granting him
concessions he comes off as a bit of a
prima donna in the New York magazine
article again just like anybody else has
the right to participate in politics but
this idea that the youth are the people
who ought to be trusted is really really
dumb how about good ideas ought to be
trusted as speaking of somebody who's
writing when they're 17 I can say that I
was Dumber when I was 17 than I am now I
know more things I know more about
politics I I think I am a more moral
person all of life is about getting
better at what you do and when you're 18
years old and you're getting coverage
and the cover of the New York magazine
as the future of the Democratic Party
that's a bit
of a problem but maybe the future of the
Democratic Party isn't in fact David hog
maybe the future of the Democratic Party
is Chelsea Clinton so after years of
people on the right warning that Chelsea
Clinton would run for office and her
saying no yesterday she came out and she
said maybe great she says if my City
Council the were to retire if my
congresswoman were to retire my Senators
and I thought I could make a positive
impact I think I would really have to
answer that I'd really have to ask my
answer to that question for me it's a
definite no now but it's a definite
maybe in the future because who knows
what the future is going to bring
because every generation must run for
office every single one we have to have
Kennedy's and Clinton's and Bush's and
Trump's all the way down it's just going
to be awesome we have to have a legacy
of paternalism in politics that
stretches across generations it's it's
one that honestly if I have to pick
between David hog and Chelsea Clinton
I'll pick David hog honest to god and I
can't stand David hog I'll pick him just
because at least he's fresh blood at
least he's somebody who's engaged he's
not just doing it because mommy and
daddy were doing it and then got rich
off of it it's really insipid it's if
we're gonna have legacy politics all the
way through then we've got a real
problem in the country the reasons
Ahnold Trump became president is
partially because he went around
punching Jeb Bush like there in the back
of the sixth grade class with the
teacher not watching that's the feeling
I think that is going to accrue thanks
to the dominance of big names in
politics the bushes and the Clintons and
and all the rest of it there is a sort
of push back that's happening on a broad
level now meanwhile President Trump is
getting himself in hot water but he's
not getting himself in hot water with
the American public I think I think he's
getting himself in hot water with the
press mostly and the stuff that he
should be getting in hot water for is
not the stuff he's actually getting in
hot water for with the press so
yesterday he was talking about the malar
probe and the president came out and
said if I want I can lead the mother
probe as I've said before the president
should stop talking about the muller
probe he should let it take its course I
don't think it's gonna come up with
anything but he keeps kind of feeding
the fire on this thing and this is
driving the media up a wall so he said
that he can lead the Molen probe if he
wants he also tweeted out about security
clearances there's another thing that he
tweeted he was watching TV last night
and he tweeted just watched former
intelligence official Philip Mudd become
totally unglued and
cultivating wonderful Paras Dennard ever
been in security clearance dinar
destroyed him but mud is in no mental
condition to have such a clearance
should be revoked at Sean Hannity okay
so the President of the United States
it's just important to note when we say
that we now live in a reality TV
universe filled with stupidity yeah
and President Trump loves pardons
because he can sort of hand them out if
you win The Apprentice and then he likes
security clearances because he can
withdraw them if you lose the apprentice
so he doesn't like Philip Mudd because
Philip Mudd saying mean things about him
on TV and so he wants to withdraw his
security clearance this is not good
president thing it's not good at not
good executive branching we should be a
nation of rules not a vindictive
vendetta's and when the president does
this it undercuts his own case but
Democrats continue to focus in not so
much on that but on stupidities they are
focusing in on for example the President
of the United States saying this there's
an ice event yesterday and what she
honored a particular ice agent who
happens to be Hispanic and here's what
Trump said and the media lost their
minds over this Adrienne come here I
want to ask you a question so how did
you come become it you're not nervous
speaks perfect English come here I want
to ask you about that 78 lives you saved
78 people okay I don't know why he would
say the guy speaks perfect English I
mean I guess he looked at me and said
Hispanic dude I have to point out that
he speaks perfect English because the
president is suffice it to say sometimes
thick so that is not a great statement
but the media decided this is a deeply
deeply important scandal it's it's it's
indicative of something deep and
horrifying about President Trump most of
the country though is more focused on
the fact that the Democrats are ripping
on ice generally then on the fact that
the president says in politic and dumb
things about members of ice the
president is actually honoring that guy
the Democrats would disband ice so while
the president is honoring that guy in
the dumbest possible way the Democrats
would actually disband ice and get rid
of the borders they're sending out
people with shirts that take up the wall
at the VMAs and then they're ripping on
Trump for saying this guy speaks perfect
English again does that make the
president brilliant no but if you
contended that I think that you are
delusional
doesn't mean that the president is a
racist I think it means the president is
racially insensitive but did we not know
that before but when it comes right down
to it if I have to choose between the
racially insensitive
I who supports ice and the person who is
perfectly politically correct who does
not support eyes most Americans are
going to side with President Trump on
that meanwhile members of the media are
still pushing President Trump on the
mauler stuff in Trump is responding here
is Chris Cuomo who is again in a running
gun battle with his brother for
stupidest Cuomo brother and he starts
ripping into Cory Lewandowski who again
is about as bright as a tomato in Corey
Lewandowski is a former campaign manager
for president Trump also an incredibly
dumb man and and here is Cuomo actually
being dumber than Lewandowski which is a
pretty astonishing feat I mean you
really have to try to do that if you've
got nothing to hide you talk how many
times as he said I want to sit down with
Muller I want to tell him
so do it well look I ana I hey the
president isn't talking to Robert Muller
not because he's not man enough but
because if he does he understands that
any sort of Mis statement will be used
by Muller to charge him with obstruction
of justice or perjury the idea there is
no perjury trap and this is what the
media are saying now if you have nothing
to hide why don't you talk to Muller
okay guys if you have nothing to hide
why don't you let the IRS audit your
books-- every year if you have nothing
to hide why don't you let the police
into your house it this is this is just
foolishness the president isn't going to
talk with Muller because the president
is fond of saying ridiculous things and
in a legal context that is a huge
mistake the the reason that I'm bringing
all this stuff up with President Trump
is that Trump says dumb things on a
fairly regular basis but the media are
always at 11:00 you can't tell the
difference between their treatment of
him saying he speaks perfect English and
the president should talk with Robert
Muller and the president just
complimented Vladimir Putin compared the
United States to Russia there's no
difference in tone or tenor it's exactly
the same tone exactly the same tenor if
you if the media actually cared about
having an impact on politics they might
have some dynamic range they've no
dynamic range everything is played at
the full possible volume and that means
that everything is basically muted your
brain if you're if you are in a room
with a very loud constant noise your
brain will start to tune it out that's
what the media have become at these days
and that's why President Trump even
continuing to ramp stuff up doesn't have
all that much impact on President Trump
himself okay time for a thing I like and
then we'll get to a thing I hate so
things I like there is a HBO show that
starts off kind of bizarre like a mix
between billions and Arrested
Development and then it sort of morphs
into a King Lear Shakespearean drama
it's pretty good I'm not gonna say
fantastic but it is compelling the the
show is called succession Brian Cox is
the star of the show he's definitely the
best thing in it all of the characters
are deeply unlikable as per most HBO
shows but if you are a fan of sort of
corporate and corporate espionage kind
of stuff and family drama then this will
work for you and it does have a couple
of really fantastic scenes the best
performance is actually given by I'm
trying to member of the name of the
actor Matthew McDermott I think um but
he's he's really terrific he's not a
member of the family here's a little bit
preview everything I've done I've done
for my children I know I've made
mistakes but I've always tried to do the
best planning because I love them have
you thought about the possibility that
your children are actually scared of you
oh I want to broadcast I don't want to
show is pretty good it's obviously based
on Rupert Murdoch yeah whether it's an
actor take on Rupert Murdoch or not
doesn't really matter but it does it
does actually highlight a serious
problem for folks who tend to be
powerful which is that their kids very
often are deeply deeply screwed up and
that is because when you grant sense of
entitlement to your kids it's difficult
for them ever to recover from it so
that's that's a challenge that parents
who are more powerful or rich wealthy
accomplished have to we have to pass on
to their kids okay time for a couple of
things that I hate so Facebook has
decided they are now going to rank users
oh goody how could this possibly go
wrong according to the UK Sun Facebook
is rating users based on how trustworthy
it thinks they are this one the this
won't absolutely this will not result in
people spamming other people's accounts
to try and ding their trustworthiness
rating it absolutely won't happen it's
not like people have ever used social
media to target others before users
receive a score on a scale from zero to
one that determines if they have a good
or bad reputation but it's completely
hidden so you can't even check your own
reputational score which is just great
the rating system was revealed in a
report by The Washington Post which says
it's in place to help identify malicious
actors Facebook tracks your behavior
across its site and uses that info to
assign you a rating
Tessa Lyons who heads up Facebook's
fight against fake news said quote one
of the signals we use is how people
interact with articles for example if
someone previously gave us feedback that
an article was false and the article was
confirmed false by a fact checker then
we might wait that person's future fall
News feedback more than someone who
indiscriminately provides false news
feedback on lots of articles including
ones that end up being rated is true the
problem with that of course is that a
lot of the fact checkers happen to be
left-wing and those fact checkers are
going to confirm the preconceived biases
of a bunch of folks on the left
Facebook's tendency toward the left is
going to be exacerbated by all this is
why when Facebook says oh we just run
algorithms how you define the algorithm
is exactly the issue
it's like saying we always abide by the
law well it depends what the law is if
the law is bad then you abiding by the
law isn't particularly useful is it so
Facebook again failing to understand its
own bias and that's going to create some
problems hey other things that I hate
today so Oprah Winfrey has now promoted
the shout your abortion movement the
July issue of O Magazine according to
life news.com featured shout your
abortion founder Amelia bono and it's
inspiration section because nothing is
more inspirational than you talking
about how you killed your baby Bono who
began the campaign to urge women to brag
about aborting their unborn babies soon
we'll be coming out with a new book by
the same title according to the report
I'm sure it will be a massive bestseller
nothing says fun quite like having shout
your abortion on your coffee table she
told the magazine how it all began in
2015 she says when I found out the House
of Representatives had voted to defund
Planned Parenthood I kind of unraveled I
opened Facebook and without thinking
wrote like a year ago I had an abortion
at Planned Parenthood and I remember
this experience with a nearly
inexpressible level of gratitude I hit a
hit post 153 words later and everything
changed and then her friends shared her
post on Twitter with the hashtag shout
your abortion on some level I didn't
turn alized the Sigma Y honestly wasn't
to shame then why hide wasn't out of
character for me to disclose something
so personal online what was out of
character was my silence which is to say
you're an oversharer but then she felt
bad about this because you should
actually feel bad it turns out about
killing babies is probably not something
you should shout but now this is
something that the left has I'm old
enough to remember when Bill Clinton
said things like safe legal and rare the
idea being that abortion was a bad thing
that was still necessary under certain
circumstances I think that's a bad
argument but it's at least closer to a
moral argument than abortion is an
unfettered good that you should brag
about and a some sort of mark of
maturity and womanhood and yet that's
what the left is pushing these days a
culture that does not have shame is a
culture that is soon going to degrade
into full government dependency
seriously shame culture guilt is a very
good thing yeah I think there's a
difference in a guilt culture in a shame
culture of shame culture is one where
people are
in doing the right thing ago guilt
culture is one where morality is
inculcated in individual citizens they
feel bad about doing the wrong thing
Western civilization tends to be more of
a guilt culture is Lomb exhibition tends
to be more of a shame culture but if
there is there is neither shame nor
guilt then what you end up with is a
culture where every sin is considered a
positive and we're all supposed to cover
for you because after all all behaviors
are supposed to result in equal benefit
to you whether you have an abortion or
not whether you're single mom or not
it's all supposed to end up exactly the
same way for everyone this is how you
end up with a society of people who are
dependent on the largesse of others who
happen to be more responsible citizens
anyway it's just it's it's bad stuff all
the way through but Oprah's always been
a deeply socially liberal person and
this is why she ever ran for presidents
I think a lot of her veneer would would
immediately come off I think that she's
got this cross-cultural appeal that
comes out that starts to be washed away
the minute that she comes out as the
partisan hack that she actually is okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the ben
shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright ford
publishing 2018